marie-christine cloutier qui est
directrice du projet de regroupement des
entreprises pour la vaccination
bonsoir alors d'abord vous vous
travaillez pour ce que vous êtes une
directrice chez cae qui vous prêtent au
gouvernement pour coordonner sur un
regroupement d'entreprises quel est
votre rôle exactement effectivement donc
ces airs qui contribue à l'effort actuel
à la mobilisation du privé actuellement
et sert bien accepté de me presser au
ministère la santé et des services
sociaux afin de coordonner cet effort là
que les entreprises ont bien prête à
faire pour accélérer la vaccine concret
alors on parle de regroupement il ya des
entreprises comme cascades bombardier
telus notamment qui font partie du
regroupement et c est bien sûr dans
plusieurs grandes entreprises qui ont
levé la main pour dire on souhaite
contribuer à l'effort de vaccination au
québec mais aussi et ça va faire partie
notre rôle
il ya plusieurs pme qui ont levé la main
tu dire on souhaite contribuer également
fac notre rôle va vraiment être de
d'identifier des potentiels sites de
vaccination en entreprise mais aussi
d'autres services que certaines
entreprises pourraient fournir du prêt
un personnel en matériel est super et un
espace puis on veut s'assurer par le
maillage entre les différents services
que les entreprises pourraient faire
pour qu'on puisse on a toutes le même
objectif commun accélérer la vaccination
au québec est vraiment envie de donner
un répit aux au réseau public
comment ça va fonctionner dans les
entreprises qui va faire la vaccination
est également équipé un moment où on est
on sait cet engouement la des
entreprises on sait qu'elles veulent vd
ont fait qu'elles veulent contribuer et
elles le font gratuitement également
donc sociale sophie le premier point
maintenant en termes de méthodologie on
en est vraiment un stade préliminaire
quand on travaille très étroitement
évidemment avec une star la santé des
services sociaux afin de déterminer
quelle sera la bonne méthodologie pilat
les différentes méthodes qu'on mettra en
place pour s'assurer d'avoir des
personnes pour vacciner des sites et du
personnel de soutien qui va faire de
chacun de ces six là
des endroits simple efficace face
d'acteurs mais qui va vacciner c'est
quel type de personne où on va trouver
le personnel pour procéder à la
vaccination
l'objectif est qu'elle offre du privé
soit en complémentarité avec l'argent
public on veut s'assurer que les gens
qu'on va trouver sont des gens qui sont
par exemple en entreprise certains ont
des bureaux de santé avec des
infirmières des médecins
donc on va s'assurer qu'on est bien
capable d'optimiser l'offre du privé et
d'utiliser ces personnes là pour
vacciner a ensuite d'entreprise quand
vous dites vous allez vous assurer de
tout faire ça vous faites ça vous vous
donnez combien tu as à quel moment ça
parle parce que on était à peu près
c'est quand même effectivement ans et
quand on a des objectifs ambitieux dans
les prochaines semaines ayant un site
web qui va être mise en ligne qui va
nous permettre vraiment de répertorier
l'offre de servir de chacune des
entreprises qui veulent contribuer on va
être en mesure d'identifier qui sont les
potentiels sud de vaccination
mais quelles sont les offres que les
entreprises veulent faire toujours
gratuitement à ces sur une base vraiment
volontaire garde suit donc avoir
répertorié tous ces services là ça va
nous permettre d'identifier où sont les
sites à désigner où sont les personnels
qui pourrait nous aider avec nez dans
ces sites ne qui quels sont les espaces
qu on pourrait ajouter notre site web
l'oeuvre est déployée rapidement comme
vous dites dans les prochaines semaines
afin qu'on puisse vraiment répertorier
leurs des entreprises et de leurs on va
être en mesure d'aller de l'avant avec
l'offre de vaccination du privé la
fédération des chambres de commerce du
québec rapporte a déjà mis en ligne ou
en tout cas déjà lancé un appel aux
entreprises qu'on nous dit qu'on est
rendu à 400 entreprises qui ont répondu
à cet appel de la fédération des
chambres de commerce du québec qu'est ce
que vous allez faire de ces 400
entreprises qui ont déjà levé la main en
prenant on est très enthousiaste à
l'idée de savoir que tel engouement
l'objectif c'est d'essayer d'aller à un
niveau de précision un peu plus élevé
parce qu'on va dessiner on va désigner
des sites de vaccination
il ya quand même certains critères à
établir il ya des protocoles en place
qui vont éteindre être établie par le
ministère de la santé des services
sociaux
donc on veut aller un peu plus loin
évidemment
travaille très étroitement avec chacune
des associations pour s'assurer que ces
entreprises ne soient identifiés quand
ils vont on va inviter chacune des
associations à faire appel alarmant et à
les inviter à aller remplir le sondage
sur le site web est vraiment pas qui va
nous permettre de répertorier d'enceinte
en uniforme à les critères à être
établies par exemple mais ce que je
comprends c'est que l'appel qui a déjà
été lancé auprès des 400 entreprises qui
ont répondu à l'appel d'offres ccq
devront avait ensuite aller se
réinscrire sur le site web qui sera
éventuellement créé par le gouvernement
du québec
oui et c'est très rapidement
effectivement bon très rapidement donc
quand on dit très rapidement c'est à
partir de quelle date ch mais je me
permets d'insister
non en fait que ça fera dans les
prochaines semaines
on est vraiment à l'élaboration du site
présentement donc on espère que tous les
deux trois prochaines semaines
l'épopée du froid mise en ligne il va
avoir de la communication qui va écrire
aux entreprises à cet effet là pour
qu'on puisse agir rapidement et élaborer
les deux vaccinations matinée est donc
arrivé à 200 mille doses administrées en
entreprise par semaine
il ya des objectifs ambitieux on est en
discussion à ce moment avec le ministère
pour clarifier ses objectifs la
clarifier les fientes et s'assurer qu'on
est capable d'y répondre mais avec un
engouement qu'on voit présentement on
est extrêmement confiant plus verte
qu'on va être en mesure de supporter à
les objectifs qu'ils ne feront
communiqué merci madame futur au plaisir
mais pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit